hi I'm Fiona McDonald and today we're
finding out what chemistry means to the
average Australian how would you
describe chemistry like to use nobody
yeah chemistry I would say some sort of
chemical compound chemistry is a science
of the elements of our universe
interaction of two things table and the
table their favorite
periodic table chemistry you can define
in the relationship chemistry no
scientific way
that's it what is chemistry it's a love
between guys and girls chemistry is
animal attraction the feeling you have
in in your stomach yeah someone that
like makes you want them immediately
drawn to them and you feel you you just
want to be around them well I think of
it like chemistry between a boy and girl
like just that special thing that um you
can't explain and then it also just
think about chemistry at school where I
had to time memorize according to you
guys chemistry is more about love than
science but don't forget that without
science there is there love because it's
all home runs baby